Marlys is with us in Minnesota hi Marlys
how are you good how can we help okay
your phone is your phone is doing funky
can you speak directly into it can you
hear me come you know a little better
yeah let's try it okay okay so my
question is please drowning in that and
we don't know what to do
our goals are want to be debt-free
Builder credit because they're Qatar
right now 5:30 we want to build a home
and we don't really want to buy a home
because we don't want to be paying for
the next 15 30 years our income is 50
for his income is 58 thousand a year
before taxes and he also gets $20,000 VA
disability
our rent is 1635 a month in savings
right now we have ninety one dollars in
collection what employment what are you
calling about what's your question we
just want to figure out our finances
worth were in debt to our eyeballs we
owe $5,000 in collections we owe okay it
says on my screen your husband was laid
off yes that's a good piece of
information okay
yes how long how long has he been laid
off today it's been a whole week and
he's done unemployment 558 what was he
doing
Aviation he works on airplanes and he
didn't used to make like 900 a week and
we just got your Mustang or bills on
time analysis now it's going to go Spurs
back down but past due payments because
like that are you working no I'm not
working I shall have a job I have a job
but it's at the airport they're not
right now I can't
before they pay anything you still
though I had literally third training I
just got you know some yeah and I mean
we for student loans that okay hi let's
stop a second stop a second all the
bills and all the debt don't matter you
don't have any come right now right okay
we have to work on your income first
just to get food on the table first
lights and water second food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities so
the first thing he needs to do is look
at all of these people jump on Anthony's
Instagram or mine either one there's a
list of posted on those feeds as a list
of companies that are hiring and he
needs to go sign up at Amazon sign up at
overeats
sign up for somebody and get to doing
something because three hundred dollars
and they'll cut it even with the 20
thousand dollars coming in from a
disability so the first thing you do is
just take any job you can get anywhere
as fast as you possibly can and get an
income coming in and that keeps you from
getting further behind or as you said
spiraling backwards because that's
that's a hopeless situation and so we
just if we can just keep food coming and
keep lights and water coming with the
disability and with some side gigs some
side hustles right now until he can get
back to work you'll probably get back to
work the airline industry will start
moving again the aircraft will start
flying again and it won't be that long
but if you can do that in the interim
that'll get you going and do go to Dave
Ramsey comm slash hope and get that
14-day free trial and you guys start
watching financial peace but it's gonna
be all about getting some income coming
into your house right now and just take
care of the most important stuff there
SS stuff can sit for a month it's not
the end of the world